[Music]
boardgames used to be the perfect
activity for all the family until we
realize that some of them were actually
pretty offensive stay tuned until the
end to see one of the worst games of
monopoly if you love board games as much
as we do don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we are showing you ten board games
that weren't for kids what shall I be in
nineteen sixty-six young girls dreamed
that they could grow up to be more than
just housewives this is why this
educational game showed them suitable
career options for young women they had
the chance to become a teacher a nurse
and airline hostess and actress a ballet
dancer or a model and that's it
compared to this the male version of
this game he'd young boys the chance to
become lawyers or astronauts their goal
was to become the number one girl in one
of these jobs by collecting for school
cards of one profession while some girls
can actually be interested in this kind
of job they had to learn that they might
not be able to do it that's because they
needed to have the proper personality
for each of the prospective careers for
example if they got too excited it was
bad for airline hostess and nurse but if
they had a nice hairstyle it was good if
they wanted to become an airline hostess
and actress or a model being overweight
was bad for 50% of the career choices as
they had less chance to become an
airline hostess a ballet dancer or a
model fortunately in 1976 the game was
updated and young girls had more
opportunities like going to medical
school in law school when we think that
this game could have had an influence on
the future of little girls it was
certainly not meant for kids the sinking
of the Titanic these people decided to
turn a tragedy into a game and people
are not laughing while it was nice to
see the movie Titanic we shouldn't
forget that it was a drama and not a
comedy this was not all fun and games
some people didn't understand that when
they encouraged families to play this
game the Titanic was sinking and players
had to race around to rescue passengers
from their staterooms and rushed the
lifeboats before the ship sinks then
after the ship sank they had to get
enough food and water by visiting
Islands and drawing cards to stay alive
while they waited for the rescue boat to
appear the first ones to make it won the
game while all the other passengers were
lost there is only one player who could
save their passengers people were
offended by this not only because they
turned the tragedy into something fun
but also because they rewrote the story
there was no island
anywhere nearby when the Titanic sank
and it was a dumb idea to change the
story just to make things more
entertaining while the whole game was
not a total failure the problem was that
they associated it with something that
really happened changing the name for
the name of a boat that never existed
would have made the game less offensive
public assistance it's never fun to have
to ask for government welfare payouts
and this is why it should never be
turned into a game while some people
really do need this kind of help it is
insulting to see a game portraying them
as people who just want to take
advantage of the system just so you can
clearly understand why this game was
offensive
the tagline was why bother working for a
living while playing this game people
could move around the board in two
different tracks they could go on the
working person's rough or the
able-bodied welfare recipients promenade
the spaces on the board contained
instructions on how much money to
receive or pay out and they could also
collect welfare benefit and working
persons burden cards the two kinds of
players both had either paydays or
government welfare payouts and the goal
was to see who had the most money after
taxes this game portrayed people who
need public assistance as lazy people
who just want to get the money you work
hard for this is why it was banned in
the 80s and always known as politically
incorrect
we should never encourage this kind of
prejudice and this is why kids shouldn't
be allowed to play this game it looks
like the game makers didn't think too
hard either when they were working on
this board game game Monopoly this game
came just in time for the decades new
gay right movements this board game
looked just like any other game of
Monopoly but with a little gay twist the
original playing tokens were replaced by
other tokens that were supposed to be
gay themed like one stiletto heel a
leather cap handcuffs a Jeep a blow
dryer and a teddy bear in the original
game people could buy houses and hotels
but this time they could buy bars and
bath houses as if the LGBT community was
only interested in that another thing
that was new at this game was the family
pride cards each car described an
important gay man and the players had to
identify him to move to any space on the
board then there was the camp cards that
encouraged you to do something
stereotypically gay like yelling the
word fabulous or striking a pose there
is still a debate on whether this game
was really offensive or not some people
might think that it portrayed gay people
in a stereotypical way while
other members of the LGBT community just
decided to embrace it and laugh out loud
while playing this game no matter what
gay monopoly should never be taken too
seriously anyway you probably won't see
this game anymore because Parker
Brothers who owns the actual Monopoly
game shut them down with a copyright
lawsuit blacks and whites we don't know
if this board game was trying to teach
us a lesson or if it was simply
incredibly offensive according to the
publisher blacks and whites was meant to
depict housing discrimination through
the absurdities of living in different
worlds while playing on the same board
at the beginning of the game players
could either choose to be black or white
and we are not only talking about a game
of chess they had to choose if they
wanted to be black or white people those
with white skins started the game with 1
million dollars and had the chance to
buy a property anywhere on the board but
if you are black you started the game
with only $10,000 and couldn't buy many
properties they could live in the inner
ghetto the outer ghetto the lower
integrated neighborhoods the upper
integrated neighborhoods the newer
estates and the older estates as you can
guess not a lot of people chose to be
black and most of them lived in ghettos
there were also cards that could make
players gain or lose money and as you
can guess the whites were gaining money
and the blacks were losing money just
because some people are luckier than
others while it was meant to teach
people a lesson the discrimination
against race should never be a game just
try to talk to your kids instead out
with the Jews during World War 2 Nazis
went as far as creating games to
encourage young kids to hate Jews that
was not the only game but this one was
so offensive that Nazis themselves
criticized the game this is why it
became the most notorious board game of
the war as it represented the terrible
way people used to think at that time
this game was published before the war
in 1938 hoping that it could
indoctrinate kids to support Adolf
Hitler out with the Jews or Juden raus
was a sort of a mall game of Monopoly
and Alma in this game you just had to
roll your dice to move your token to
Jewish houses and collect Jews they were
represented by little pawns wearing
pointed medieval Jewish hats then you
had to escort the Jews to a collection
point by rolling the dice once again the
player who was the first to expel six
Jews won the game obviously the designer
of this game probably regrets ever
thinking about this nowadays just like
parents who let their kids play with
this game but this is also a lesson to
be learned as we hope that something
similar won't happen ever again you can
now see a copy of out what
Jews on display at a Holocaust Museum in
London but that's the only place where
we want to see it beat the border this
game didn't only encourage kids to
become criminal
it was also totally racist that's
because the goal was not to simply cross
the border it was not about illegal
immigration even though we could imagine
that one president would like to play
this game it was about smuggling illegal
substances and selling them they never
actually said what it was but the goal
was to still make money buying and
selling what they used to call kilos and
as it is difficult to cross the border
with them we can imagine that they are
not selling pencils but actually they
could be selling Kinder Surprise as this
candy is illegal in the United States
anyway players started the game with
$1,000 and then had to cross the border
to buy kilos from various sources what
makes this game racist was that these
sources all had Mexican names like
Eduardo Ronaldo or Jose then you had to
try to cross the border and sell the
kilos in US cities like Tucson and New
York you could be busted by various US
government agencies if you carry kilos
and can even buy some things that would
help you out like lawyers or fake IDs
this game was clearly turning kids into
racist criminals and we can't believe
that some parents ever encouraged that
this game shouldn't cross the border it
shouldn't even cross someone's mind
[ __ ] on the melon patch just by
looking at the title you know that there
is no way this game can turn out to be
right in case you don't know about this
associating black people with
watermelons is considered to be really
offensive nowadays that's because when
slaves won their emancipation during the
Civil War they started growing eating
and selling watermelons this is how the
fruit became a symbol of their freedom
but as revenge some white people turned
it into a symbol of laziness
childishness and unwanted public
presence this is why turning it into a
game was simply racist people played the
role of black men who tried to escape a
patch of melons there were also angry
farmers and grandmothers who acted as
threats there were also some
distractions like seed spitting contests
and melon races to win you had to reach
the end space first by rolling a die and
avoiding pitfall spaces once again some
white people took the symbol of the
watermelon and turn it into something
terrible we can't believe that there was
a time when people actually believed
that it was a fun game to play but one
thing is sure no kid should ever be
allowed near it nowadays this game was
so terrible that it even inspired many
ma
counterfeits but no matter what you can
burn any version of this game parental
supervision is advised
five little n-word boys just when we
thought that things couldn't get worse
people decided to put the N word in the
title of a game there is no way anything
could go right with this game the only
moment when anyone can say the n-word is
to say that you should never say the
n-word and we don't even dare to say it
now this is why we can't believe that
one of the most offensive racial slurs
was part of the title of a product that
was marketed just to make things worse
it was a target shooting game the game
included five pieces that looked like
little black children and a pop gun
rifle that fired corks the goal was to
shoot down the five little children the
winner was the player who managed to
shoot down a predetermined number of
pieces having a heart as cold as ice was
a must to win in this situation we
shouldn't even shoot criminals unless we
are in great danger let alone poor
innocent children and just when you
thought that it couldn't be more
offensive this game also included a man
eating a watermelon we think that we
don't have to explain why no kid should
ever know that this game exists the only
n-word anyone should have used while
marking this game was the word no no
don't ever think about turning this into
a game get oh ah Polly while you might
think that people were really different
in the past this game was actually
created in 2003 yet oh ah Polly looks
like monopoly except for the fact that
you buy stolen properties and get points
or lose money in many inappropriate ways
for example you can sell soap to stupid
high school students who think it's
illegal substances and gain points you
can also lose money for having to post
bail some of the things you can be
involved in if you'd rock hard included
being arrested for trying to smuggle
four kilos of illegal substances across
the Mexican border or meeting a rapper
at Weinstein's you could also go to
cheap Trick's Avenue if you felt horny
owned a crack house or get carjacked
just to make things clear that going to
school isn't cool in the ghetto the game
was also full of grammar mistakes if you
want to take things even further you can
also buy redneck ah Polly fortunately
these games are really hard to find so
we hope that no one will ever play that
game but just realizing that someone
once thought about it makes us lose
faith in humanity what do you think was
the worst game on this list don't be shy
to answer in the comments section down
below we love to hear what you think and
that's it for 10 board games that
weren't for kids if you liked this video
don't forget to subscribe and please
give us a big thumbs up thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]